this program is brought to you by Emory
University
well there are a million little reasons
why this was you know something I was
interested in like um putting my hair up
or stabilizing something while I cook
you know um tying things up but in the
end it just felt right when I was
younger in elementary school they
actually fit me with a prosthetic hand
two or three times but I never I never
stayed on for more than a few weeks it
was three o'clock in the morning and I
wrote dr. send Alice a really vague and
poorly written email and what she
responded with a beautifully written
essay next morning and um she asked if I
was available to talk about it over the
phone you know and I said of course it
so she called me the next day I believe
sometime late in the afternoon and she
just told me about the program um I did
a immunology blood test i think it was
before coming here for the evaluation
and then it was a week-long evaluation I
was extremely interested but I hadn't
made a decision until about want to say
day to the main thing that was in my
mind on risk wise was regarding the
medication post-surgery I honestly
especially after meeting the team and
speaking to everyone did not worry about
the actual surgery it was just the rehab
in medication that mainly the
immunosuppressed
it was like a surreal moment oh and I
mean up until even when I got here I
thought it was a dream it's kind of
funny because a lot of times when I walk
through just a hospital who or not
people will look at me and be like hey I
feel your pain I broke my thumb last
year and I'm like oh so you totally up
your skate wouldn't go it's kind of a
hard thing to explain because it's only
been a few weeks and it's new to me so
to me the fact that I'm doing anything
at all he's kind of amazing rehab is a
little bit slow at times and there are
moments where you know I get frustrated
but that feeling doesn't last as long as
there's progression I'm happy eventually
in long term I just hope that I'll be
able to incorporate my hand into you
know just my daily functions without God
or thinking like
without being paranoid we're overly
protective overall I'm just happy and
hopeful
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University